rappel la question orale de monsieur
jean claude lenoir à madame la ministre
de l'artisanat du commerce et du
tourisme
bien merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre merci d'abord de vous être
déplacés pour répondre à ma question qui
concerne l'avenir du fisac comme chacun
sait le fonds d'intervention pour les
services le commerce et l'artisanat
c'est un outil précieux madame la
ministre pour le maintien notamment du
commerce dans les petites villes en
milieu rural c'est un fonds qui étaient
autrefois alimenté par des taxes payées
par les grandes surfaces
bruxelles nous obliger à changer de
méthode c'est aujourd'hui une subvention
de l'état un fonds d'état comme chacun
sait ce sont des fonds qui n'est qu'ils
fondent comme neige au soleil alors
aujourd'hui vous avez un stock important
de dossiers madame la ministre
vous êtes régulièrement sollicités nous
recevons réponse une lettre lettre type
qui indique que le précédent ministre
avait été généreux dans la réception des
dossiers mais que voulez vous ce sont
les élus qui envoie les dossiers c'est
pas les gouvernements qui les suscitent
et aujourd'hui vous avez un nombre
important de dossiers qui ne trouvent
pas de réponse alors cela évidemment
nous préoccupe beaucoup parce que des
dossiers sont actuellement en panne et
aussi bien des petits commerçants que
des artisans qui doivent mettre aux
normes leurs ateliers que des
collectivités qui veulent aménager leurs
centres n'ont pas les moyens pour
réaliser ces projets
là il ya une réflexion qui était
annoncée dès la fin d'année dernière
par celui qui était en charge du budget
et qui nous annonçait qu'un texte était
en préparation alors nous intéressons
évidemment de près ce texte moi même je
me suis forcée candidat pour faire
partie d'un petit groupe qui allait
réfléchir à ce sujet
j'ai eu l'occasion de vous confirmer mon
intérêt pour ce type de dossier et nous
sommes donc dans la tente d'un texte ou
alors sur ce point
évidemment nous interrogions parce qu'il
ya un rapport qui a été produit par
notamment notre collègue queyranne
sur l'avenir du fisac et les conclusions
qu'il propose ne nous conviennent
absolument pas il s entend que le fisac
devrait être réservée pour réparer les
dégâts créés par les
catastrophes naturelles et il suggère
que les opérations plus locales soient
supportés par les collectivités locales
ce qui est absolument inacceptable
ce sera un transfert de charges dont
nous n'avons absolument pas le premier
sou alors ma question est les doux
madame la ministre à bord évidemment qu
est ce que vous envisagez de faire par
rapport au stock j'ai pas besoin de
chute et que moi même j'ai quelques
dossiers qui sont actuellement 900 ans
et j'aimerais savoir même si
individuellement vous pouvez pas vous
prononcer pour chacun d'entre eux dans
cette séance mais assez rapidement
savoir quelles sont vos intentions puis
deuxièmement quelles sont les intentions
du gouvernement par rapport à venir du
fisac qu'est-ce qui est en carton est
calé calendrier la discussion d'un texte
qui nous est annoncé merci bas de la
ministre merci mon cher collègue parole
est à madame sylvia pinel ministre de
l'artisanat du commerce et du tourisme
de la parole d'un ministre merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je vous
remercie pour cette question qui est
importante pour les territoires
importante pour les entreprises
concernées et je partage votre analyse
le fisac joue un rôle important un effet
levier tout à fait significatif qui
permet le développement la modernisation
et le maintien dans certains territoires
d'une activité commerciale ou artisanale
je ne reviendrai pas puisque vous l'avez
largement évoqué sur la situation qui
est la mienne et celle que je dois gérer
face à une accumulation significative et
importante de dossiers dans tous les
territoires puisque nous atteignons à
l'heure où nous parlons à peu près mille
huit cents dossiers qui correspondent à
peu près quatre années d'exercice
budgétaire pour les financer dans votre
département vous m'avez signalé plus de
sept dossiers je crois qu'ils sont
évidemment importants pour votre
territoire comme le sont la plupart
d'entre eux ce que je souhaite et vous
l'avez évoqué je m'y étais engagé
c'était mener une évaluation pour
identifier les difficultés juridiques
que nous avions pu percevoir des
différentes réformes successives du
fisac qui pouvaient pénalisé à la fois
les entreprises mais aussi les
collectivités territoriales cette
évaluation a été menée dans le cadre du
projet de loi sur l'artisanat le
commerce et les très petites entreprises
que j'aurai l'honneur de présenter
devant le parlement au printemps
prochain pour ceux qui tombent en ce qui
concerne le sénat je proposerai une
réforme de du fisac tout en le
maintenant je veux vous rassurer de ce
point de vue mais pour sortir de la
logique du guichet pour entrer davantage
dans une logique d'appel à projets qui
correspondra à au financement des
priorités voulue par le gouvernement
voulue par les territoires aussi dans ce
qui est je peux vous donner un certain
nombre d'indications ce qui pourra par
exemple concerner les opération
collective de modernisation du commerce
et de l'artisanat portait bien souvent
par des intercommunalités mais aussi des
opérations individuelles comme le
maintien de certains commerces en milieu
rural ou dans les politiques de la ville
qui sont très sains très importante
parce que au-delà de l'aspect économique
ces commerces et artisans jouent un rôle
de lien social que vous avez bien
identifiés et nous devons le favoriser
le protéger le valoriser et en même
temps une action particulière sur la
sécurisation des commerces et notamment
des commerces les plus sensibles je
pense aux bijoutiers je pense aux
buralistes puisque les faits divers nous
le rappellent malheureusement assez
souvent et puis sur ceux qui en ce qui
concerne le stock c'est une solution
c'est une un sujet un peu plus difficile
mais nous travaillons avec mon l'ags
chargé du budget pour trouver une
solution pour financer ces dossiers
malheureux en attente bien sûr peut-être
que tous les aspects tous les sujets
tous les dossiers ne pourront pas
trouver une solution en gestion avec le
ministre du budget et ce que je souhaite
c'est que dans ce choix que nous devrons
mener nous puissions directement plus
directement aider les entreprises du
commerce et de l'artisanat parce que ce
fisac doit réellement être utilisé pour
aller vers ces entreprises et non pas
forcément comme cela était pu comme cela
a pu être le cas par le passé être
orientée sur d'autres aménagements
urbains qui peuvent être financés par
ailleurs par d'autres politiques j'ai
bien entendu votre souhait de travailler
sur cette question je peux vous dire que
certain nombre de réunions de
concertation seront menées avec les élus
locaux avec les différents représentants
des collectivités territoriales
bien entendu les parlementaires qui le
souhaitent peuvent parfaitement être
associé à ce travail que qui je l'espère
pourra être consensuel parce qu'il va de
l'intérêt de nos territoires et de
l'intérêt de ces entreprises merci
monsieur noah
bien monsieur le président m'avait dit
merci pour toutes les précisions que
vous apportez dire que les informations
que vous avez porté à la connaissance de
la haute assemblée concerne l'ensemble
de ses membres et nourrissent bien
entendu pense que les actes vont suivre
des intentions telles qu'elles sont
exprimées en tout temps des tricots je
vais vous dire que nous il ya une
adhésion totale pour ce qui concerne
aussi bien les orientations que vous
avez rappelé que du projet de loi et qui
est en préparation sur la façon dont
vous allez le conduire notamment en lien
avec les parlementaires il nous confirme
vraiment mon intérêt pour ce sujet et en
ce qui concerne d'autre part la gestion
des stocks alors je voudrais profiter de
ce droit de réponse pour parce que je ne
pouvais pas évidemment dans un premier
temps l'exprimer appelez votre attention
sur un point très important qui est
laide à au maintien des pompes à essence
en milieu rural vous savez
qu'actuellement une procédure cpdc merci
monsieur
ministre chers collègues de confirmer
mon point de vue c'est à un vrai
problème puisque la disparition des
stations services soumises à mise aux
normes d'ici à très peu de temps
entraîne un phénomène que l'on connaît
les personnes pour se ravitailler en
essence vont dans les grandes surfaces
et évidemment abandonne le commerce
local alors là aussi il ya vraiment
aprem de crédit je connais bien le
directeur général qui s'est déplacé de
mon département pour deux dossiers en
particulier qui font partie d'ailleurs
17 dossiers vous avez identifié il faut
remercie d'avoir regardé parmi les
milliers de dossiers ce que j'avais pu
porter à votre connaissance mais je
souhaite parce que ce ne sont jamais des
sommes très importantes mais très
significative et dont l'impact lorsque
on peut mobiliser ces fonds est
considérable puisse être réglée dans les
meilleurs délais la ministre pour avoir
le plaisir de vous reparler d'eux y voit
de ses sujets dans un avenir proche
parce que je n'attends que de bonnes
réponses après les propos généreux que
vous avez tenir merci et encore merci
cher